para poder hacer prototipos de hardware
en nuestra bits y bot vamos a colocar la
parte central de nuestra tarjeta de
prototipo encima de nuestro arduino
necesitamos colocarla en algún lugar
aquí estoy viendo si uso un corcho de
vino para colocar encima de la
superficie entre estos dos componentes
en la tarjeta del arduino el corcho no
es conductor y es muy fácil de cortar
por lo que sería muy bueno para ayudar a
colocar nuestra tarjeta de prototipo
necesitamos ver cuál es la altura en
nuestra tarjeta de prototipos
necesitamos ver cuál es la altura entre
nuestro conector de energía y nuestro
conector usb y resulta que están a la
misma altura así que cortamos nuestro
corcho a la altura correcta
aquí estoy quitando el lado rugoso con
la segueta y me acabo de acordar de qué
debo hacer esto sobre mi pedazo
descartado de madera para no rayar mi
mesa al terminar de cortar el corcho
pueden ver que el corte no está
perfectamente derecho para arreglar esto
vamos a cortar el corcho un poco más
grande de lo necesario un poco más de
dos centímetros en este caso ahora
tomamos la lima y el corcho y limamos
los extremos del corcho para dejarlo
suave y derecho la lima nos permite
quitar poco a poco el corcho para poder
dejarlo a la altura correcta
ya que tenemos el corcho a la altura que
deseamos ponemos un poco de silicón
caliente nuevamente del tamaño de una
moneda pequeña y empujamos el corcho en
el centro de nuestra porción de silicón
y lo sostenemos allí hasta que seque
nuestro corcho va a ayudarnos a sostener
nuestra tableta de prototipos oye me
acabo de dar cuenta de que el corcho
cubre algunos de los números en mi
arduino que es importante poder ver y
como ya no puedo mover ni despejar el
corcho voy a cortarle un pedazo usando
el cúter y resulta que me fue muy
sencillo cortar el corcho en esta
dirección con el cúter llenamos el borde
para dejarlo limpio y cortamos con
cuidado lo que quedó pegado del silicón
caliente en la tarjeta con cuidado uso
el cúter y lo despejó con el
destornillador
ya tenemos nuestro soporte y parece que
nuestra tarjeta de prototipos va a
quedar bien estable
tenemos cinta de doble cara en la parte
de atrás de nuestra tarjeta de
prototipos para ayudarnos a pegarla en
su lugar quitamos la cubierta de papel
de la cinta doble cara para dejar al
descubierto el pegamento y poder dejar
fija en su lugar la tarjeta de
prototipos solo quitamos las cubiertas
en las secciones en donde va a estar en
contacto con la base de corcho y el
conector usb ya que lo tenemos alineado
tomamos nuestra tarjeta de prototipos y
la colocamos y presionamos con cuidado
en su lugar esto nos va a permitir
conectar diferentes componentes en su
lugar como resistencias capacitores
transistores y probar diferentes
configuraciones para experimentar con
nuestra bits y botó